بي في الثامن من يوليو عام 2008 انطلقت
قناه ام بي سي الفارسيه القناه المختصه
ببث الافلام والمسلسلات الاجنبيه المترجمه
الى اللغه الفارسيه بجانب بث برامج
ترفيهيه واجتماعيه بالفارسيه واليوم بعد
14 عاما تملك قاعده جماهيريه راسخه وخاصه
من الشباب في وفقا لاخر دراسات الربع
الاخير من 20 22 استطاعت ام بي سي فارسي
تفوق على كافه القنوات الاجنبيه في ايران
دراسه جديده اجرتها شركه ابسوس العالميه
لابحاث السوق لقياس احصاءات قناه ام بي سي
الفارسيه خلال الربع الاخير من عام 2022
تاتي القناه في المرتبه الاولى من حيث نسب
المشاهدات متفوقه على كافه القنوات
الاجنبيه وفي المرتبه الخامسه بعد القنوات
المحليه
66% من الجمهور الايراني على درايه بقناه
ام بي سي الفارسيه مقابل 64% في اخر
الاحصاءات 8.7 من 10 هو مستوى رضا مشاهدي
قناه ام بي سي الفارسيه عن المحتوى
المعروض ايضا
8.4% هي نسبه ارتفاع الاداء العام للقناه
بالنسبه للشباب من الفئه العمريه بين 15
عاما الى 19 عاما وهي زياده بنحو 3% عن
نفس الفتره في عام 2001